this is wiki bear and we just turn on
his switch back here hello i'm wiki bear
what's your name
conan o'brien conan christopher o'brien
American talk show host to meet a guest
appearance as himself in the TV sitcom
30 rock yes Wow that's very cool I'm
surprised you knew that that's great I
can answer any question you have
I'm wiki bear okay wiki bear what
popular animated children's show
features a character named Rainbow Dash
checking now that show is my little pony
which also features Pinkie Pie a
hyperactive horsey who loves to throw
parties
hey that's right Thank You wiki bear
speaking of horses who like to party
the legendary Russian Empress Catherine
the Great was rumored to have died while
attempting to have sex with a horse
giddyup Cathy whee
I I didn't ask about that wiki bear
they say the harness used to lower the
horse on top of her broke and the
Empress was crushed to death imagine the
last thing you see before dying isn't
your friends or loved ones but a horse
is erect penis but let's change the
subject of something better for kids
what family movie featured the voices of
George Lopez and drew Barrymore
that 2008 hit was Beverly Hills
Chihuahua which spawned two
straight-to-video sequels yeah Wow Ricky
bear I didn't know that
speaking of Beverly Hills hits notorious
mobster bugsy siegel was staying in
Beverly Hills when he was shot twice in
the head while reading the newspaper
stop the presses and all of Bugsy's
brain activity I was even no no okay no
one wants to hear about that that's one
of the bullets shout out Siegel's
eyeball we bounced around the room like
a super bowl okay that's fine
Ricky Barrett we really need to find
something appropriate but she was
staying at his girlfriend's house which
goes to show you kids never stick around
after sex
wham bam thank you man it's the only way
to go no no no lookee Barrett we really
need to find something appropriate for
kids now what's the most this is good
what's the most popular flavor of Ben
and Jerry's ice cream
the answer is half-baked a scrumptious
combination of chocolate brownies and
cookie dough yum yum okay well thank you
Wicky bear that was perfect than we're
done and while you're in the freezer be
sure to check behind the ice cream for a
severed head
that's how infamous serial killer
Jeffrey Dahmer preserved his victims
and guess what in addition to those
heads Dahmer also preserved two human
skeletons which he used to decorate a
dark altar dedicated to himself all
right now we all need a little me time
time forget it Dahmer was later beaten
to death in prison and he's probably in
heaven right now murdering angel
okay
you